Wow. What an amazing couple of days. I've
learned a whole ton of stuff, and what an
amazing time to live, working on the internet.
There is so much cool technology — progressive
web apps, WASMs, machine-learnings, information
on how to make our sites fast, great things
about user experience, we have service workers,
the official logo, Google IO last month said
that service workers is like the biggest step
forward in a decade, and it's given us off
line, and push notifications, and our websites
could be even more performant, and there are
articles, and Twitter, and social media is
going on about how fast our websites have
to be, and I feel really tired, and it's draining.
I want to go back to a better time where things
were more old school, a bit more slower, and
louder, and uglier. So I'm going to throw
all of the cool stuff that you've learned
over the last year and try and go back to
that awful experience. I have a couple of
content warnings. I do have some flashing
imagery in my talk. It's not a huge amount
on the screen, but you will see the icon up
in the corner. There are disorientating sounds.
You will see the icon up in the corner before
it starts playing. There is some questionable
JavaScript, so, judge me all you want, but
it won't make it any better! My name is Remy
Sharp. Maybe you've seen my work, JS By. I
run FFConf in the UK. I've got a couple of
projects, NoDemon. And I was a child of the
1980s as I'm stressed with Mr T with the beard
and the earrings. I grew up in the UK during
the 1980s, and there was an explosion of technology
happening at that time. I was privileged enough
to be in a household where my father was into
computers as well, and — like it was a thing
that was happening — and we had this machine.
This was my childhood machine that I remember
using. This is a ZX Spectrum 48k from Sinclair.
It is like the kind of Apple or Microsoft
of the time. In Europe, I think it was Time
X. This came out in 1982. Now, there are couple
of machines prior to that. In 1980, the Sinclair
released the ZX80 for £50. For a home computer
in 1980 was staggeringly cheap compared to
the fact that, in the 1970s, there were machines
the size of rooms for thousands of pounds.
So, all of a sudden, for £50, about EUR200,
you could only a computer in your household.
This is what I had as a kid. Instead of being
parented, I played games on this. Mum and
dad, don't watch. I loved that one of the
features here is the key is autorepeat, key
feature is like the keys autorepeat, and,
to load the after the wear on to these machines,
you would have a thing called a cassette tape,
this is like an old shit USB stick, not anywhere
near as robust, and all kinds of things would
go wrong with the tapes. You would take your
tape, load it into the cassette player, and
you would press play. That would wire into
your Spectrum. You wired the Spectrum into
your television, and you would wait. And you
would wait. And, sometimes, the games wouldn't
load, and sometimes, the tape would unspool,
so all the tape would come out. Sometimes,
it would look like Jimi Hendrix here. Often,
you would have to wind it all back again.
A canvassed Twitter to ask people for those
of you who had these things, what would you
do to try and encourage the thing to load?
Some people would leave the room so the computer,
this God-like thing had to be alone. Some
people turned the machines upside-down. I
would pray to the thing, please load, please
load. To be fair, I still use this technique
on my phone. So, in truth, most of my childhood
was spent listening to these games loading,
so what is what I want to recreate for you
and bring back the old school. This is using
the only technology I know, which is a browser,
obviously. Just to give you full context,
this is what it sounded like, and looked like.
I've forgotten the content warning, so there
will be loud noises here, and I will turn
it down as we are going, and it's a bit flashy
too. So you want it from the beginning. [Electronic
screeching sounds]. If you're a kid of six
or seven and waiting for this game. That's
what you have to listen to. Okay? And this
is just the loading screen. This is just the
thing to tell you this is what it might look
like. [Laughter]. Assuming the tape wouldn't
go bad, and the Spectrums were buggy. I'm
going to remake that. So, the Spectrum, that
loading experience, one of the key parts is
the sound. So, the sound is broken up into
three parts: you've got the pilot signal which
is like the steady tone that happened at the
beginning; then there is a sync signal which
is a burst of sound; and then I've got data.
What we were list he can to just then was
data. Like, I can do this. I know there's
a web API for sound. I'm going to get a new
audio context and create an oscillator and
set the frequency of the oscillator to about
830 which is the right frequency. I had a
friend open me up in Audacity and tell me
what the frequency was. I connected to my
destination and I start. [Single electronic
tone.]. That solid frequency is the pilot
signal. Cool. Next bit. Okay. Next bit is
making a distinct sound. And I know how to
make white noise. I know that I can chuck
random data into audio, but this is distinct,
and it needs to sound right otherwise it's
just all wrong. So, I didn't work on this
— worked on this 12 months on and off, but
12 months, learning about sound, learning
about tones, and frequencies, and processors,
and promptly forgot all of that stuff, and
you can just fill buffers with samples. So
I didn't need to know anything about how sound
works to be able to create this. One amazing
part of the web that I absolutely love be
I was able to go to a website called worldofspectrum.org
and filled with game content, old files, specifications.
There are people who have reverse engineered
the entire hardware and made it work and documented
all of that and shared it on the web. I know
that the amplitude of the wave form is completely
irrelevant. The way the sound works is that
it measures this line as a pulse. The point
where it crossed the zero mark and goes down
below, that is one pulse. This has a length
of 855T state. A T state is one operation
that the ZX Spectrum can perform, running
at 3.5 megahertz, doing 3.5 million operations
a second. This is 855T states. That is a quarter
of a millisecond. So to get this right, I
have to make a quarter of a millisecond sound.
A pair of these pulses is a binary zero, and
twice the length is a binary one. I have a
bunch of numbers now. I can use a bit of maths.
I take my sample rate of 44 megahertz, which
is like the default audio con text sample
rate, and I take my 3.5 megahertz — my T-state
length. I want to get the number of samples
required to match the T state, the T length,
and it's basically the length at 855 multiplied
by T, multiplied by sample rate plus a little
bit more so they get a whole number. I can't
have a half sample. For binary, binary one,
I get 22 samples. I'm sure no-one will learn
anything from this bit of code. Don't worry
if you're not following it at this point.
I will create a buffer that gives me a binary
1 and a binary 0. Here I basically just have
the number of samples 11 for zero, a float
array that has twice the length, and I populate
with a plus one and a negative one which gives
me a binary zero. I can now go and get the
JSConf home page, I've got the length of bytes
by putting an array in an array. I multiple
the bytes by eight bits in a bite because
there are — multiplied by the length of
one, and I get the number of samples required
to create the buffer to be the right size
to get a play in JSConf EU HTML. I set an
audio context, set the buffer. Populate it
with this line here — just magic, okay?
I'm going to connect that to my destination.
Yes. So this is JSConf as audio. I will put
my volume back up so you can hear it clearly.
[Rapid electronic screeching]. Yes, this is
the JSConf music for next year, I'm telling
you. [Applause]. Yeah! Basically just hurt
a lot of people's ears, and you're clapping
me! Sound done. Next off is the loading bars,
the super important part of making awful loud
ugly images. So, I think a really cool back
story to the loading bars? Spectrum. The original
ZX80 had a chip called the ULA which is the
main brain of the computer, and they had a
restricted number of chips, so they had — sorry,
restricted number of pins on the chip, and
they had one pin managed all the display.
That same pin dealt with reading all of the
audio coming in, so when audio came in, it
would disrupt the display. Ever the engineer,
this is not a bug, this is a feature, because
you can see approximately what the baud rate
of the data going over the audio, and the
engineers why kind of like, "We can see it's
loading" so this is basically like a loading
bar from the 1980s. In fact, they coded it
into the hardware, and the other computer
systems went and coded it into their software.
The Commodore, for instance, added this as
a feature in their software when you loaded
games. So I can't just take the bytes from
JSConf and dump it into a canvas and say the
zeroes are yellow and the ones are blue because
it would do it too quickly. I need to take
the audio I just generated, run it through
a processor, and then emit bits that I will
then render on a canvas. I have three choices
for this. I can use an analyser node but that
didn't really work for me, it was it wasn't
giving me enough of the samples that comes
off the audio. And then I've got a script
processor node, and the audio worklet. Actually,
the script processing node has been deprecated
as of August 2014 in favour of the audio worklet,
and the audio worklet doesn't really have
much support in many of the browsers today,
so I chose the script processor node. But,
it's pretty much the same. The they're cool,
but basically, the script processor will block
the main thread which is what I want. I want
it to be a little bit slower. Okay. So, I've
got my loud nasty noise. I connect up a script
processor, and the audio event fires, and
I get all the samples for that audio event.
I'm going to run through all those samples.
I'm going to do the opposite of what I was
doing before. I'm going to look for the edges
of the sound. The point where the sample rate
goes from zero to one and comes back down
again, that's the width of my pulse. I'm going
to build up pairs of pulses, find the bits,
the pairs of pulses which make a bit, and
then build up a bit into a byte, and then
render it as a bar on the screen. The first
time I ran this, I was doing a lot of work
with arrays and moving data around in arrays,
and I ran a little performance test where
I put all the audio through my code. It was
like processing 200 or 300 samples through
these three or four minutes of noise. It was
kind of slow. I could feel this buffer.shift
is taking up three seconds. I thought it's
the not mutation going on, but when I refactored
it a ill will bit and changed it for a splice,
it completely changed the performance profile.
That was because of the way I was working
with arrays. An array contains hundreds of
samples, shifting one off at the beginning,
JavaScript is not going to do that thousands
and thousands and thousands of times. In fact,
I changed from regular arrays to typed arrays,
and it completely flattened the performance
profile. There is ten milliseconds of the
most amount of time it spends rather than
hundreds of milliseconds. The way that I think
about this is a regular array is just a point
in memory which the operating systems doesn't
really know how much it is going to store
in memory, and it's any type can go in there.
You can put objects, and strings, and it's
not super optimised when it is in memory,
but a typed array can only be one length,
for starters, so the operating system allocates
that amount of memory, and the actual elements
inside of the typed array, they can only be
either a U in 8, or a floating point, but
it has a specific length, so you can specifically
jump through that typed array. Typed arrays
were superb for this, and it's runtime performance
rather than Typescript-like protection of
your — I don't use Typescript, not because
it is bad. So, my code is able to use a script
processor to consume audio that I can then
paint blue and red bars for when I get data.
Heads up audio people. Ready? [Single electronic
tone]. Those the bars around the edge. The
blues are the ones. The yellows are the zeroes.
Yeah. Okay. [Applause]. So I have slow, and
I have loud, but I don't have ugly yet. Now,
I don't have any time for Web P, or PNGs,
gifs, or those fancy image formats, what we
need are really old up supported Spectrum
1980 image formats, so this is the image format
I'm going to render — none of this new stuff.
This is how the image is rendered in a Spectrum.
It is a really cute image format — or I
think it is. It is always exactly 6,912 bytes.
It is broken up into these sections. The first
three-quarters are pixel data. It is literally
if the binary is zero. It is white, and, if
it is black — it is on or off. The first
quarter is dedicated to the first third of
the screen, and then the last section at the
end it dedicated to the attribute data which
makes up the colour that you can see at the
bottom, and it is just a byte, a single byte
gives you see the ink, the paper, the brightness,
and that means basically from instead of white
we can have grey if the brightness is off,
and obviously blink, because that's important!
Okay? A great part of this code is I think
I can — I get to abuse bit-wise operations,
and I can say for any point in my 6,912 bytes,
I have this index of 4 thousand. Where does
that live in each quarter? I can do a bit-wise
shift 11 which is not only like really performant,
because it is low-level JavaScript, but it
makes me look like an elite hacker! This is
more code that renders bits. Look, it has
got bit-shifting, modulus, multiplication,
maths. Yeah! Even awake/sleep at the end to
make it go a little bit slower. With that,
I can now render all of these super old deprecated
formats. These are deal .screen files from
the world of, real dot screen files. Manic
Miners was one of the early games. I've got,
Chase HQ before there are others. So now I
can support really old awful image formats.
Yeah. Like I say, Web P — done. The internet
is littered with pictures of cats. I'm going
to fix that as well. I'm going to fix the
old existing old new images, and oldify them,
okay? This is this really like I won't say
beautiful aspect of these Spectrum images,
because of the way that the pixels are rendered,
there's a thing called attribute clash where
where the screen is divided into eight by
eight blocks, and you can only have two colours
on the Spectrum, so you get these detailed
colour that would can't — it doesn't bleed
into, like, other eight by eight blocks. You
can only have two colours there, okay? So,
fair enough, take a picture of my cat. I can
use a canvas API to mangle the bits. I'm going
to take an image and put that into a canvas.
So relatively speaking, that is straightforward.
I'm going to resize it down to 256 by 192
because that's how big images should be. I'm
going to use the Atkinson — Atkinson? — Atkinson
dither algorithm to get the colours to shift
across to the 15 colours that the Spectrum
has which is easy-ish if you know how to copy
and paste correctly — which is how I code!
Then determine which getting rid of the other
colours, and work out which bits of the Inc.
And which is the paper, and then ditch the
other colours to make it work, which was a
little bit more complicated. I think I kept
throwing code at it until I got something.
So this is my Twitter avatar loading it into
the page. Okay. So, my eyeball. So this is
just a regular image. Then I do the dither
algorithm, okay, and I've literally no idea
how it works. I just literally copied and
pasted and changed colours. I ended up with
this. The 8x8 block has got four colours in
it. I can't do four colours on a Spectrum
because it will look too good. I find the
two most popular colours — in this case,
black and grey — and I basically absorb
— no, I think black and red. It is going
to be a fight. I absorb the other colours
into those pixels, and I end up with this
nightmare mask. [Laughter]. But this is the
attribute mask, and in this 8x8 block I only
have pitch else that are on and off and put
the popular ones back in and I end up with
a compatible image, and I have oldified an
image. I can see this with JSConf? You can
see with JSConf the attribute clash just here
where you can see I've got a darker magenta,
and a lighter magenta because of the white,
like the bright bit makes it white. Anyway.
So, I'm now able to make images old, okay?
You can clap for that if you want to. You
don't have to. Just saying. [Applause]. Okay,
so, we're now able to make the whole of the
expert awful. I can now wire this up. I can
take my oldify technique, take my mobile phone,
take an audio cable, in theory, plug it in
my lap tap, go through the audio process,
listen, load the bars, and render an old picture
of all of you on my computer. That's the plan.
The first time I did this, I have got the
code working, and I will just plug it into
the computer. Right. Turn my volume up. Turn
your volume down over in the corner. Yes,
it's going to be some sounds. I will turn
mine down a bit. So the first time I ran it,
this happened. [Broken electronic tone]. It
does a weird submarine thing. And actually,
unsurprisingly computers are really smart.
The microphones on your phone and in your
computers are designed to get rid of background
noise, which is what I'm generating. So it
hears the noise, and it goes, "No, no, no.
We're not having that!" So, after a lot of
digging around, eventually, I found the echo
cancellation, so, if I listen to that. [Continuous
electronic tone]. You can see that I've got
a perfect sample now. With the echo cancellation
turned off, I've turned off the call features
in my laptop, I was able to get the awful
sound working properly. Okay, so, do a little
refresh. So this is my a canvas Spectrum that
I made. It's really nothing more than some
text and something to listen to the key. The
first thing I need to do is take a photo of
you. I will take a photo first. Great. Smile.
Smile! Yep. Ready. On three, one, two, three.
Weeey! Yes, I technology it's okay, you've
got your eyes open. That's cool. I have the
photo on here. I'm going to plug it into the
awed Joe Jack. I have to get — the audio
jack. From the tape, you have to do empty
quotes because, I don't know, 1980s. I'm going
to hit enter and then play. [Continuous electronic
tone]. I also find that, sometimes, it doesn't
work. I've been able to replicate bugs occasionally.
This is just like I have to hope it works.
[Screeching electronic sound]. Kind of looks
like — it doesn't look like anything what
my phone looks like. We have to wait for this.
Debugging this, I had to listen to this over
and over again! [Laughter]. You can't just
fast-forward it. In fact, actually, the bit
that I built is the only bit in all the emulated
machines don't want to build. I built the
bit that no-one wants. In real games, they
skip this bit for reasons. Are you ready?
This is it. [Cheering and Applause]. [Applause].
Pretty cool! I can barely recognise any of
you, to be fair, but it worked, right? I know
what you're thinking: I did this on a computer,
right? What about an original 1982ZX Spectrum?
Yes, I got it working in there as well. This
is a video from home. I didn't dare bring
this in. In the corner is a ZX Spectrum from
1982, made in 1982, filmed today. I've got
the audio jack of my laptop into it. What
it is rendering on the screen is actually
rendered inside the Spectrum self so I can
talk really old language for no good whatsoever,
but it worked on a real Spectrum 2. If anyone
needs to put old images on a Spectrum, come
and see me. [Cheering and Applause]. So I'm
slightly over time, but the question of why:
quite honestly, this comes up for myself quite
often. Every few months, I have this crisis
of faith, and I'm quite prepared just to chuck
it all away because really there is no point
to any of this in some respects. But, some
of the — sometimes, I work this these side
projects for love, like JS Bin. I love the
project, but at times I hate the project,
and that's not a great relationship, either.
That's not the why. Other times, I've worked
on side projects and it brings in client work
and paid work because I work for myself. That's
not normally the why, why I do these kind
of things. The why is because I enjoy kind
of using code to be creative for myself, and
I enjoy puzzle-solving, and I enjoy learning
new problems, new failings, if that makes
sense. It's mostly for fun. Thanks. [Cheering
and Applause].